béguines à tf1 l'ol paie jamais à 13
heures le premier ministre israélien
déclaré à yves mourousi j'estimerai
scandaleuse la reconnaissance de l'olp
et par les pays européens
bonsoir la cohésion européenne l'esprit
de solidarité avec les américains que
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
neuf avait très clairement manifesté
hier dès l'ouverture du sommet du sens
bourg et bien cette cohésion et cette
solidarité n'ont pas résisté à l'examen
des problèmes concrets
une fois encore madame thatcher a tenu
tête à ses partenaires la grande
bretagne a refusé tout compromis sur ce
qu'elle doit payer au budget de la
communauté comme sur les prix agricoles
d'ailleurs le blocage a été manifeste
tout l'après midi et je viens
d'apprendre le nouvel échec il est
consacré si j'ose dire il n'y aura pas
d'accord sur la contribution britannique
et sur les prix agricoles il ya un
accord à 8 mais pas à 9
madame thatcher est resté sur ses
positions gérard saint paul le récit de
la journée
même lorsque la volonté politique
d'aboutir à un résultat exister c'est le
cas aujourd'hui c'est l'intendance
européenne qui a du mal à suivre et
l'europe lorsqu'elle parle de l'iran de
l'afghanistan
l'europe un peu marqué dans une sorte de
psychose des chèques par ce qui vient de
se passer en iran un peu sous le choc de
la démission de monsieur cyrus vance
le secrétaire d'état américain l'europe
voudrait réussir à régler ses propres
affaires et pour le faire ce soir
elle applique un système anglais qui est
le mot forcing pour parvenir à régler un
problème typiquement est strictement
anglais depuis ce matin 5 propositions
tour à tour française italienne
allemande néerlandaise et puis le
nouveau allemande avec soutien français
ont été faites à margaret thatcher pour
réduire la contribution britannique au
budget de la communauté européenne
en un mot comment calculer la part
financière de londres à la bourse
commune sur la base de 1979
on était parti de l'équivalent de 5
milliards de francs au lieu de 10
milliards on est ce soir bien au dessous
des 5 milliards puisque nous nous
trouvons
aux environs de 3 milliards à payer par
les anglais 7 milliards de moins donc
qu'en 1979 et c'est maintenant même le
mode de calcul est donc la règle du jeu
commun qui sont en cause
margaret thatcher dit encore non et fait
des contre-propositions
comme tout est lié l'accord sur
l'augmentation des prix agricoles 5% ce
qui avec toutes les corrections
nécessaires donne une augmentation de
10% pour les agriculteurs français
cet accord risque de rester un accord à
8 contre 1 si l'on ne règle pas la
question du financement britannique
la présidence italienne a fait un très
bon travail de préparation
les nouvelles propositions françaises
exprimées par le président giscard
d'estaing est très rapidement soutenu
par helmut schmidt ainsi que par
beaucoup d'autres pays avait donné ce
matin un regain d'optimisme ce soir on
joue les prolongations
margaret thatcher au fond est placé
devant un choix simple choisir entre
l'échec où le succès au moment où
l'europe a besoin de serrer les rangs
ici luxembourg tf1 voilà ça c'est ce que
nous disait gérard saint publié une
demi-heure et bien depuis
comme je voulais dit l'échec est
consacré il n'y a pas de prolongation
madame thatcher refuse tout compromis
sur la contribution britannique et sur
les prix agricoles
alors on verra il faudra attendre
quelques heures pour voir quelles
conséquences aura cette attitude de
madame thatcher
comme prévu donc depuis ce matin le
secrétaire d'état américain cyrus vance
le chef de la diplomatie américaine a
offert sa démission au président carter
qui l'a acceptée c'est son adjoint
warren christopher qui va assurer la
terrine les lettres échangées entre
cyrus vance et jimmy carter mérite
d'être citée car elle éclaire
parfaitement les raisons de cette
démission
cyrus vance écrit je sais combien vous
avez posé votre des signes votre
décision concernant l'iran l'opération
de tabaski a tourné à la catastrophe
j'aurais voulu pouvoir vous soutenir
mais pour de nombreuses raisons dont
nous avons parlé je ne peux pas vous ne
seriez pas bien servi par un secrétaire
d'état qui au cours des semaines et des
mois qui viennent
n'aurait pas pu vous soutenir
publiquement sur un problème et une
décision d'une extraordinaire importance
réponse du président carter j'accepte à
votre avec regret votre démission parce
que vous ne pouviez pas soutenir ma
décision de l'opération de sauvetage en
iran vous avez pris vous la bonne
décision en démissionnant je sais qu'il
s'agit pour nous d'une oeuvre pour vous
d'une affaire de principe contre
continue monsieur carter et je respecte
vos raisons en fait ce qui vient de se
passer concrétise un changement de
politique aux etats-unis mais pour
carter disons que c'est une tuile de
plus de washington dominique bromberger
avant même que la tentative de sauvetage
des otages américains en iran n'était
engagée et n'ai tourné à la catastrophe
cyrus vance avait présenté sa démission
à jimmy carter comme une décision
irrévocable la lettre manuscrite de
démission du secrétaire d'état porte
d'ailleurs la date du 21 avril trois
jours avant que les avions c-130 et les
hélicoptères sealion ne décolle pour
l'iran aujourd'hui en expliquant sa
décision cyrus vance a assuré jimmy
carter qu'il continuerait de le soutenir
à l'avenir et affirmé que le seul
désaccord qu'il avait avec lui portait
sur cette opération
en fait on sait que le secrétaire d'état
s'était opposé à toute forme d'action
militaire qu'il s'agisse du minage des
ports iraniens d'un blocus naval ou de
l'opération de sauvetage et qu'en ce
sens là il s'était séparé des autres
conseillers du président brown
secrétaire à la défense brévine ski
conseiller pour les affaires de sécurité
nationale aussi bien que de jimmy carter
une façon plus générale le départ de
vente partisans de la conciliation
notamment avec l'union soviétique ne
fait qu'entériner un certain
durcissement de la politique américaine
ignorance telle qu'on avait appelé en
comparaison avec la ligne d'origine ce
qui était une ligne qui à l'origine
avait été adoptée par le président qui
avait voulu l'appliquer en 1977
relativement plus souple tant vis-à-vis
des pays de l'est que vis-à-vis des pays
du sud
cette ligne avait été progressivement au
fil des années au travers de certaines
hésitations sans aucun doute le
abandonné par le président la décision
d'engager une opération militaire en
iran confirme cet ajustement est le
secrétaire d'état donc jugé bon de se
retirer un peu plus tôt qu'il ne l'avait
prévu
quant à carter il a dit ce matin qu'il
regrettait le départ de vente mais qu'en
raison de leurs désaccords il s'agissait
là d'une décision logique
et puis pour la première fois depuis le
début de la crise iranienne
il a quitté washington pour rendre
visite aux blessés du raid
la conséquence la plus claire de cette
démission survenu en pleine crise
internationale et qu'elle va renforcer
l'impression à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur du pays que carter est un
homme autour de crise
tout s'effondre sa politique son
administration est aussi ses chances de
réélection
dominique bromberger tf1 washington à
luxembourg un porte parole de monsieur
giscard d'estaing a souligné tout à
l'heure que la france appréciait cyrus
vance pour sa loyauté son efficacité et
puis aussi pour la confiance qui
n'aspiraient souvenez vous la dernière
tournée du secrétaire d'état en europe
avait pour but de convaincre qu'il
fallait absolument prendre des sanctions
économiques et politiques au niveau
européen contre l'iran et cela pour
éviter qu'on en vienne à une opération
militaire pour libérer les otages
ce qui était contre les principes en
effet du chef de la diplomatie
américaine
les européens ont pris un premier train
de sanctions économiques et politiques
mais ça l'a pas empêché l'opération de
tabac ce dont ils n'ont pas été prévenus
aujourd'hui les étudiants islamiques
menace à nouveau de faire passer les
otages ont jugement les otages dont une
grande partie aurait été transféré dans
plusieurs villes d'iran et les étudiants
averti qu'une nouvelle intervention
américaine enverrait je cite tous les
otages en enfer d'un seul coup les corps
des neuf américains tués at abbas dans
la collision entre le c 130 et
l'hélicoptère ont donné lieu à une
odieuse démonstration devant les caméras
de télévision les photographes puis un
chantage dont il émane souligné
l'inutilité autour de leur restitution
finalement les corps des américains
seront rendus représentant du pape de la
croix rouge internationale et du
gouvernement suisse qui seront chargés
dé restituer aux familles et d'éviter ce
site qu'il puisse servir pour la
propagande anti iranienne
un envoyé du vatican monsieur capucci
monseigneur capucci pardon ancien
vicaire de régis de jérusalem est partie
pour teheran téhéran où il ya eu
aujourd'hui quatre attentats à la bombe
en plein centre de la ville christian
bousquet l'explosion la plus violente et
la plus meurtrière s'est produite à 17
heures locales dans un quartier central
de téhéran la bombe placée dans une
voiture en stationnement sur la grande
place comme unis a provoqué la mort de
deux personnes tandis que cinq autres
moins été blessés sous l'effet de la
déflagration une dizaine de véhicules
ont été détruits et les vitres des
bâtiments qui se trouvent sur cette
place comme eni ont volé en éclats peu
de temps après les forces de l'ordre ont
désamorcé une deuxième bombe dissimulée
dans un sac eux placés dans une petite
rue qui jouxte la place
craignant qu'une autre explosion les
gardiens de la révolution ont alors
chasser les très nombreux curieux qui
s'étaient rassemblés sur la place et
c'est aux cris de à mort carter que
cette foule s'est dispersée
car pour tous ces gens il ne fait aucun
doute que ces attentats en série sont le
fait des américains ou de leurs
complices iranien attentats en série oui
car une autre bombe avait déjà explosé
plus tôt dans la matinée placée dans un
cinéma proche de la place communique
toujours la même
elle avait fait quatre blessés cette
explosion avait même été suivie par deux
autres lunes dans une banque et l'autre
dans un bazar dans l'état actuel des
choses il est impossible en tout cas de
savoir qui sont les véritables
responsables de ces attentats
oui les américains on peut être bon dos
je ne sais pas mais il ya aussi les
rivalités politiques en iran qui peuvent
s'exprimer de la manière dont il
convient de voir grande émission en
direct d'yves mourousi à 13h devant le
mur des lamentations à jérusalem c'était
à l'occasion des fêtes du 32e
anniversaire d'israël et le premier
ministre menahem begin est venu
longuement s'expliquer sur sa politique
monsieur begin a souvent condamnés l'ol
paie l'organisation de libération de la
palestine qu'il désigne comme un ennemi
implacable mais rarement il aura 10 avec
une telle force qu'il n'était pas un
instant question de traiter avec l'ol
paie même si celle-ci renoncé dans sa
charte à la destruction de l'état
d'israël pour monsieur begin vous allez
l'entendre reconnaître officiellement
l'ol paie comme on le fait en europe est
à ses yeux scandale je pense que c'est
un scandale que des pays européens que
n'importe quel pays européen qu un pays
civilisé reconnaissent une organisation
qui veut détruire le petit état juif et
sa population
c'est en vérité je ne peux pas utiliser
un autre terme c'est un scandale c'est
un véritable scandale si leur île paix
devait modifier sa charte concernant
israël s'il voulait s'accommoder
l'existant sur alès que
pour penser un dialogue vous savez c'est
une question que j'entends dans chaque
interview mine mais change jamais
pourquoi répondrait à une telle question
hypothétique n'est ce pas ils se
réunissent à damas à beyrouth au caire
chaque fois qu'il ya un conseil des le
ps réunis il y à des rumeurs ils vont
ces modérés ils vont modifier certains
articles de la charte mais ce n'est
jamais arrivé
ça n'arrive jamais au contraire mais je
voudrais vous dire quelque chose vraie
mordue maintenant du coeur
personnellement s'il devait y avoir des
changements
je dirais n'y croyez pas nous avons
l'expérience du passé c'est notre ennemi
implacable qui ont vraiment décidé de
l'essayer de détruire israël
ils n'y ont pas réussi mais c'est leur
programme c'est ce qu'ils veulent faire
l'intention qui les anime et courra qui
me disent n'est ce pas s'ils disent
sociaux cela pour moi cela ne sera pas
n'aura pas pour moi est une véritable
valeur l'armée française a commencé à se
retirer du tchad aujourd'hui l'ordre est
venu de la présidence de la république
bien sûr depuis le début des hostilités
entre les factions rivales au pouvoir au
tchad et qui ont transformé la capitale
n'djamena en champ de ruines et de
misère et troupes françaises ont reçu
l'ordre de ne pas intervenir et se sont
regroupées sur l'aérodrome mais leur
situation devient pratiquement intenable
et elles vont progressivement se retirer
probablement vers le gabon et le
cameroun dans une première étape
il ya un peu plus de 11 cents soldats
français au tchad de régiment de
parachutistes au régiment d'infanterie
de marine
un régiment d'artillerie de marine avec
blindés et hélicoptères leur évacuation
va prendre plusieurs semaines
une première fois en 76 des forces
françaises s'étaient retirés du tchad
elle y était revenu à la demande de ce
pays en 77 et nous allons voir avec
françois debré quel rôle elle ont joué
depuis tant sur le plan militaire que
civil
après une dizaine d'années de combat
contre ce que l'on appelait les rebelles
tout bout et qui aujourd'hui se
disputent le pouvoir à n'djamena l'armée
française aujourd'hui représentent
l'essentiel de l'infrastructure d'un
pays déchiré par une longue guerre
civile avec l'accord des diverses
tendances tchadienne les 11 cents
soldats français regroupés en djamena
maintient un semblant d'efficacité aux
principaux services du pays santé
transport ou communication après avoir
soutenu son ancien adversaire hisséne
habré un moment rallié au gouvernement
de l'époque l'armée française s'est
efforcé depuis 79 de respecter une
position de neutralité entre les 14
factions rivales qui s'affrontaient pour
la conquête du pouvoir en mars de cette
année alors que les combats reprenait
avec violence l'armée française étaient
chargés de l'évacuation par bach ou par
transall et civil français et africains
et les diplomates en poste n'djamena par
le fleuve et l'aéroport militaire
parvenait parviennent toujours les
médicaments les médecins les sens le
ravitaillement nécessaire à la
population rester sur place tandis qu'à
la terre de la base aérienne puis au
cameroun voisin une infrastructure
médicale d'urgence permettait de soigner
les blessés aussi bien les blessés
civils que les combattants
le chef de l'état goukouni oueddei
s'était longtemps satisfait de cette
neutralité vient aujourd'hui semble-t-il
de demander à l'armée française de
prendre parti dans le conflit alors même
que parvenait à n'djamena des unités
libyenne
c'est sans doute pour éviter de se
trouver à nouveau directement mêlé à une
guerre dont l'issue demeure incertaine
que paris vient de décider le retrait
progressif des forces françaises une
française de 53 ans madame ginette motte
épouse d'un entrepreneur de construction
étaient tués ce matin dans sa maison par
un obus sa famille avait refusé de
quitter djamena comme l'ont fait la
plupart des français sur les conseils
des autorités françaises depuis ce matin
et pour deux jours se tient à paris la
conférence des partis communistes
d'europe sur le thème paix et
désarmement le parti communiste français
avait lancé 30 et une invitation et il
ya effectivement 22 participants dont le
parti communiste durée cesse mais neuf
absents dont certains de marque
les roumains les yougoslaves les
italiens les espagnols ne sont pas venus
à cette conférence qui se tient à huis
clos
on sait tout de même que
le représentant soviétique boris
ponomareff a condamné l' aventurisme du
gouvernement carter pour son opération
manquée en iran mais qu'il a aussi
insisté sur les objets sur les objectifs
pacifiques de l'urss
il a conclu c'est la conscience
tranquille que les communistes lancent
un appel pour le maintien de la paix sur
cette conférence jacques hébert
inimaginable à l'époque où georges
marchais envisageait encore de gouverner
avec françois mitterrand
cette conférence des pc européens se
tient donc pour la première fois de
l'histoire du mouvement communiste
international dans un pays occidental
pour certains elle permettra de faire un
grand pas en avant quitte à reconnaître
à chacun le droit à la différence pour
d'autres elle marquera la désunion des
communistes d'europe
quoi qu'il en soit c'est essentiellement
parce que les travaux de cette
conférence sont limitées à la sécurité
en europe que neuf parties et non des
moindres ont décidé de boycotter le
rendez vous de paris
ces neuf parties notamment après
l'intervention russe de kaboul ne
veulent pas accorder par leur seule
présence un certificat de bonne conduite
international à moscou
craignant donc des répercussions
limitées de leurs travaux il est
probable qu'à l'initiative du parti
communiste soviétique
les 22 délégations présentes à paris
lens demain un appel à l'élargissement
de leur lutte pour la paix et le
désarmement
prenons exemple sur le puits puissant
parti communiste d'europe occidentale le
parti italien absent aujourd'hui cet
appel pourrait s'adresser aux
socialistes aux sociaux-démocrates et
même aux chrétiens ceux qui ont fait le
voyage pour paris répondrait ainsi aux
absents ce sera la façon de leur dire
dans la lutte du communisme
international c'est comme dans toutes
les luttes
rien n'est plus condamnable que la
politique de la chaise vide
marie laure augry les autres nouvelles
ces journaux élections cantonales
partielles ce week-end et candidat du
parti communiste a été réélu à
courbevoie et candidat du parti
socialiste à hyères dans le var rien de
la majorité en gironde à
castelnau-de-médoc litige par contre à
vincennes fontenay dans le val-de-marne
les bureaux centralisateurs ayant
constaté des irrégularités de vote du
selon les communistes candidat udf
on n'a donc pas pu prononcer les
résultats il faut désormais attendre la
décision du tribunal administratif de
paris
demain pour la première fois grève
générale de l'ensemble du personnel d'un
enseignant d'éducation nationale dans le
primaire le secondaire
en université sont donc concernés les
services d'accueil d'hébergement de
santé les bibliothèques et les cantines
et toujours à propos des grèves dans
l'enseignement je vous rappelle que
vendredi la fed n'avait souhaité
rencontrer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ce soir europe numéro 1
christian bilhac a donné une réponse
positive comme les syndicats le
souhaitez il accepte de donner un tour
plus personnel à une concertation qui
selon lui n'a jamais cessé et qui doit
porter sur les vrais dossiers attentat à
la nuit dernière injection la future
maison de la radio corse qui devait être
inauguré en décembre prochain a été
détruite à 80 %
trois hommes armés et masqués après
avoir maîtrisé le gardien d'immeuble ont
réussi à déposer trois charges très
importantes relier des bouteilles de gaz
c'est le troisième attentat dirigé
contre fr3 des dégâts vous voyez sont
considérables
ce matin à cinq personnes dont un
médecin ont été poignardés dans un
hôpital de bobigny parent malade pris
d'une crise de démence
une des personnes blessées décédé
quelques heures plus tard le forcené qui
avait réussi à s'enfuir a finalement été
arrêté à bauguil évasion spectaculaire
aujourd'hui dans une prison de milan dix
des douze évadés ont sitôt honte aux
sites ont été repris par la police parmi
ceux-ci l'ancien membre des brigades
rouges corrado al houni et à un bandit
considéré comme l'ennemi public numéro
un d'importantes forces de police ont
aussitôt investi quartier pour débusquer
les derniers fugitifs 3482 titulaire de
la carte orange ont perdu leur procès
contre la sncf ces voyageurs exiger le
remboursement partiel de leur carte
orange à la suite d'une grève de cinq
jours en janvier dernier sur le réseau
de la banlieue parisienne pas de
remboursement donc en cas de grève les
réfugiés cubains joue de malchance en
route pour la floride leurs bateaux ont
été pris dans une tempête certaines
embarcations ont chaviré
pour le moment trois bateaux seulement
sont arrivés à bon port hélas une hotte
épreuves les attendent et les autorités
américaines ont en effet décidé
d'imposer des restrictions à leur entrée
aux us ans
deux morts et plusieurs blessés dans un
attentat au pays basque trois hommes
armés ont investi un autobus et n'ont
pas hésité à tirer froidement sur les
passagers soulagement enfin pour les
deux diplomates retenu en otage dans
l'ambassade de saint domingue à bogota
en colombie ils ont été libérés hier
soir dès leur arrivée à la havane après
61 jours de séquestration les otages ont
souligné le caractère plutôt cordiale de
leur relation avec les guérilleros
à noter que le commando m19 n'a pas
obtenu la libération des prisonniers
politiques qu'il réclame
le prince thibault dans les ans fils du
comte de paris incarcérés depuis samedi
et la prison de pau a été inculpé de
complicité dans une tentative de
cambriolage de tableau henri d'orléans
son frère aîné et mais les plus grandes
réserves sur les réalités des faits qui
lui sont reprochés dans la tente bien
évidemment d'information plaisante et
puis l'écrivain françoise mallet joris a
été nommé au conseil ministration de tf1
sur décision du premier ministre elle
remplace désormais au sein du conseil de
notre cher georges duby ce week-end
avait lieu la coupe inter chaîne inter
journalistes de yagg team de yachting
dans le var elle a été gagnée par la
revue océan devant tf1 europe numéro un
pour les hommes et pour les femmes
la coupe a été remportée par tf1
le temps était beau sur ces images et
bien aujourd'hui cet après midi en toute
région et températures étaient
inférieures tout de même aux normales
saisonnières il est encore frisquet
demain il fera frais toujours le matin
et les brouillards seront assez nombreux
dans la journée les nuages resteront
abondant dans le nord-est tandis
qu'ailleurs et bien le soleil tout de
même prédominera les anglais débarquent
dans le petit port de barfleur en
normandie plus précisément à l'une des
pointe de la presqu'île du cotentin
les anglais débarquent c'est en tout cas
ainsi que décrivent les journaux locaux
le projet d'un promoteur britannique
pour établir un port de plaisance dans
le vieux port de pêche une marina pieds
dans l'eau avec beaucoup de béton et
vous allez le voir dans le reportage de
jean pierre à bout pour les uns si les
anglais débarquent chez la femme tout et
pour les autres c'est une nouvelle vie
pour barfleur mais au dessus de tout
cela il ya le réveil de centimes
ancestraux vous retrouve dans
l'actualité à une autre dimension c'est
au début de ce journal on n'aime jamais
mieux les anglais que quand ils restent
chez eux dans leur île jean-pierre abou
barfleur un petit port en eau profonde à
la pointe nord-est du cotentin à 27
kilomètres de cherbourg
les ancêtres des barfleurais
construisirent au xième siècle le mot
ras avant duquel guillaume le conquérant
c'est lance à la conquête de
l'angleterre au moyen-âge barfleur
compter dix mille habitants
aujourd'hui il n'y en a plus que 720 des
retraités quelques commerçants et une
vingtaine de pêcheurs les départs fleurs
attire beaucoup de touristes surtout des
plaisanciers c'est pour cette raison que
des promoteurs anglais ont mis au point
très discrètement un projet de marina
avec un port de plaisance de 450 places
pour tenir la mer l'architecte envisage
de barrer le vieux port avec une digue
me dit d'une écluse
vous pouvez voir sur ces images le port
de barfleur tel qu'il est et tel qu'il
sera si le projet aboutit il ya un mois
les promoteurs ont présenté leur projet
au conseil municipal qui l'a acceptée le
lendemain les barfleurais qui n'était au
courant de rien ils ont découvert dans
la presse locale
mais on on est content une digue au
milieu du four c'est donc lyon gâté le
four complètement
d'après les journaux ça passerait
certainement à port lay tels faits
viennent et qui ne laisse me porte très
bien comme ça c'est beau de la moitié du
peur avec le gros mauvais temps qui se
fera tous les bateaux où ils seront ici
et là et souffriront c'est sa fin mars
le jour de pâques pour la première fois
de leur histoire
200 barfleurais ont manifesté dans les
rues du bourg une pétition a recueilli
250 signatures contre le projet mais ça
fait beaucoup de bruit dans le pays
cette histoire du port de plaisance
oui ça fait du bruit énormément savez je
crois bien qu'il ya au moins 80% de le
contre au moins un mois la population
vous êtes de bangui enfin comment je
dois dire je ne sais pas ce que ça peut
lui apporter
ça peut nous apporter quelque chose eh
bien on ne sait jamais comme ça peut
très bien la sphère divise les familles
les pêcheurs sont résolument hostiles
mais les commerçants pensent que la
construction d'un port de plaisance est
une bouée de sauvetage inespéré pour
leur commune qui se meurt excellent
projet pour quelles raisons
ce que se ressemble s'assemble cohérent
et s'adonnant de l'animation leur plein
d'animations dans le pays 20 fire il y
aura un peu de caméras se disent prêtes
c'est pour tous les commerçants c'est
bon ça les travaux coûterait 20 millions
de francs les services de l'équipement
considère ce projet comme techniquement
satisfaisant le conseil municipal l'a
acceptée par 10 voix contre trois parmi
les trois opposants le maire qui
souhaite organiser un référendum et qui
a averti qu'il ne faut pas compter sur
lui pour poser la première pierre d'un
port anglais
on ne peut pas changer la ville a dit
avec un 4 personnes comptent pour nous
rencontrer pendant une heure absolument
impossible je ne pense pas que ce soit
avec des gens qui ne parlent même pas
votre langue
je ne prenons pas un grief mais j'estime
qu'il difficiles à changer le pays
le port particulier on ayant rencontré
quelqu'un pendant quatre heures qui
avait besoin de l'interprète
on nous expliquer leur projet c'est
actuellement un peu s'ils ne sont pas
très très bien aimé dans la région j'ai
l'impression non franchement parler
alors attendez j'ai encore quelques
nouvelles sur le conseil européen vous
donner parce que finalement les chèques
les conditions de l'échec ne sont pas
tout à fait clair je vais essayer de me
retrouver dans les dépêches
tout à l'heure je voulais dit au début
de ce journal on annonce l'échec du
conseil européen sur la contribution
britannique sait de source française
le porte parole français dit ça ne peut
pas ne peut pas continuer comme ça la
discussion est close pour nous mais mme
thatcher ne veut pas céder alors c'est
terminé on ne parlera plus de la
question de la contribution brit est
mais tout à l'heure le porte parole
italien dit et qui est le porte parole
de la présidence du conseil européen car
ce sont les italiens qui ont la
présidence que pour par l'italien dit
pas du tout ça n'est pas tout à fait
terminé on va encore parler ce soir de
la contribution britannique est alors le
porte parole français vient derrière
faire une autre déclaration derrière le
porte-parole italia et 10,6 ici monsieur
giscard d'estaing me l'a bien dit nous
ne parlerons plus de la contribution
britannique voilà je regrette c'est un
peu confus mais c'est la réalité
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous au nom
de toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité
dernier journal joseph poli en fin de
programme
merci